ici le chocolat est considéré comme une
oeuvre d'art la chocolaterie cola
ouverte depuis 43 ans à maule propose
des créations originales pour la période
de pâques l'entreprise a choisi la
thématique des graines un univers
imaginé dès la fin du mois de janvier
par les quinze artisans chocolatiers la
collection va se construire avec tous
les éléments qui ont été créés comme ça
à 3,4 pendant plusieurs jours mais
parfois en prenant la forme que
quelqu'un a élaboré avec la texture que
quelqu'un d'autre a travaillé un petit
accessoire complique sur un autre sujet
on va vraiment utiliser ce qu'on a fait
pendant les froids quatre jours là comme
de la matière la matière est ensuite
travaillé à partir de la mi février pour
répondre à la demande dans le
laboratoire les créations sont décorés
au pinceau pendant plusieurs minutes
avec une peinture un peu particulière à
base de cacao
ça peut paraître un peu chaotique comme
ça mais c'est un petit peu comme un
comme un peintre le beurre de cacao fait
office de rians et comme c'est comme la
peinture à l'huile
sauf que là c'est le beurre de cacao
on est à fondre et on mélange les
pigments fatigue non alimentaires donc
l'âge et du rose je mélange avec du
blanc faire les différentes nuances de
couleurs et ensuite je je je peins je
permis depuis des figurines en chocolat
sont ensuite ajoutés pour correspondre à
la thématique un décor imaginé en partie
par une ancienne étudiante en décor sur
céramique sont soumis à faire des délais
à grosses frites et là bas en tout
premier que j'ai continué à en faire et
puis je suis arrivé à faire des petites
têtes de souris
ont été surveillés sur une recette qui
séduit pac représente près d'un tiers du
chiffre d'affaires annuel de
l'entreprise avec des créations qui se
vendent entre 10 et 100 euros
le chocolat continuera à couler à flots
jusqu'à la fin du week end